let's talk about this guy robert reich
so you know i don't tweet on the
weekends
i don't tweet on the weekends thus when
i come back on monday mornings and i'm
catching up on things
it's just like a three-day flood
basically because i try to end the day
you know midday friday so i get like
half a friday
uh you know i'm still working but like
you know just not on twitter half a
friday saturday sunday
get back on monday morning and it's just
like a two and a half day flood of
insanity
that i get to see that i missed over the
weekend and by the way i highly
recommend
that you guys do the no twitter or or no
social media or
limit it in some way on the weekend
thing try one little thing
i mean i recommend this in the book but
like try one little thing which is at
least don't even
don't bring your phone into your room on
the weekends how about that much like
don't wake up
with the first thing that you see in the
morning about the news or the craziness
and of course the last thing that in the
previous night the news
and the general state of craziness
anyway on mondays the flood just starts
again
so this is video posted on twitter of
robert wright he's
the former labor secretary under bill
clinton
and he was sort of a clinton democrat
this is what i would call a moderate
liberal 20 years ago which is probably
very similar to what i was 20 years ago
and unfortunately because progressivism
is a mind virus as you know it gets into
the system so it gets into a guy like
this who is once a decent liberal
the liberals because they don't believe
in some sort of outer truth
the the virus in essence just gets in
them destroys all their faculties and
then they just say
nonsense and endless lies much like joy
reid in the clip that we just showed
so this is robert reich talking about
critical race theory but
really really really listen to what he
says
and then we will unpack it after but
just listen
to his words and you tell me does his
words match up with what you know
critical race theory to be the so-called
party of free speech
is now going after academic freedom a
host of republican-controlled states
have passed or
are gearing up to pass bills that ban
teaching
the role race has played in the history
of american politics
policy and law conservatives lob the
term critical race theory against the
nation's tragic racial history they
don't want students to know
calling it indoctrination or
brainwashing well as an educator i can
tell you
that the real indoctrination in
brainwashing is in leaving
out this history and only teaching
children the myths
that we've always been a perfect country
always lived up to our ideals and
there's no need to reckon
with our past that's robert reich
i'll say this directly to you and we'll
post it on the twitter
you're a liar and a buffoon and a fraud
no republicans are saying don't teach
our racial history we do teach our
racial history
i think some people could argue at a
disproportionate level
we teach our racial history in all of
our public schools and certainly all of
our private schools it's taught
everywhere no one's saying don't teach
racial
history no one's saying don't teach an
honest assessment of the history of the
united states including
racial issues people are saying don't
put raci
race essentialism into the schools don't
teach
children that they are born racist and
to see everything through a racial lens
and that things like showing up on time
and hard work
are tools of being white that is
actually kind of racist
but you can't even honestly assess what
the other people are saying i'm taking
your words
for what they are and showing you that
it's nonsense you are saying
nobody want that the republicans don't
want people to be taught about race or
an honest assessment of history
that is a complete lie you are a liar
but don't
just take my word for it chris ruffo who
as you guys know is one of the leading
legal experts fighting critical race
theory in all of these states he's one
of the guys that are getting these
states
to push out the ideas of critical race
theory not to say you can't teach
about racism and slavery which we all
learned in high school
did anyone not learn in junior high in
high school about about racism about
slavery everyone did no one's saying you
can't learn about that that's what these
idiots are claiming
we're saying but it's not true but chris
ruffo who has brought many of these
lawsuits to say you just can't
indoctrinate children
and and tell children that they're
guilty over the color of their skin
which of course
they are not guilty over the color of
their skin well roofo
replied to robert reich he said i used
to respect you
but this is a flat out lie none of the
bills limiting teaching
none of the bills limit teaching about
racism they prohibit teachers from
being racist by promoting race
essentialism
collective guilt and racial superiority
theory to students
your lie is transparent and pathetic
and yes that is completely right
everything robert reich
said there is a lie okay absolute lie
note he didn't quote anything
from any of the laws that are trying to
be passed in these states he just said
his
idea of it right and this is what they
do with everything this is how
progressives win
they say these vague things that sort of
kind of sound right oh and then
the average person who's trying to live
their life is like oh my god
the conservatives don't want people to
learn about race they must be such
racist
and then of course it's absolutely
not true and and by the way this isn't
the first time that robert reich
has done this watch this video that he
put up on prageru this is from like a
month or two ago
uh criticized he put this up on twitter
criticizing
prageru gregory u is the most insidious
outfit advancing the wright's
online agenda and that's saying
something it's five minute videos
which have collected nearly five billion
views
couch typical republican dog whistles
and
outright misinformation with titles like
the myth of voter suppression
they serve as a gateway to the more
overt right-wing content pushed by the
likes of
ben shapiro and stephen crowder
prageru pushes its videos into schools
over 6 000 teachers and parents have
signed up so far
and social media's algorithms amplify
all this misinformation
when prageru's videos are assigned by
teachers for students to watch
at home more right-wing content comes up
for kids on social media
and youtube and it's spreading around
the world
israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu even used
one of prageru's videos to justify the
actions of the israeli military
backed by fracking billionaires dan and
paris wilkes
and other right-wing billionaires
prageru deploys a 25
million a year budget with with ads
targeting young people with right-wing
propaganda
schools the internet and now even
far-right leaders abroad
this organization is advancing its
right-wing ideology everywhere so the
next time you see these videos
know the truth about who's really behind
them
uh the next time you see this guy on
video know the truth
of what a douchebag he is i mean notice
he didn't have any specific
critique it's all these vague
generalities about what
prageru does just like the vague
generalities about what critical race
theory does so what did he say there
typical dog whistles and then he shows
some titles of videos he doesn't
critique any of the ideas in the videos
but the dog whistles or the titles okay
well do you want to criticize any of the
ideas around
voter fraud or anything else no you
didn't want to do that because that's
not the bumper sticker thing got it
right
uh and then uh this is this is very very
scary
do you guys realize that these
five-minute animated videos
are a gateway to orthodox jew yamaka
wearing ben shapiro
you get it he could yeah the next thing
you know you'll be eating holla on
friday okay i mean it's just
and that stephen crowder guy oh my god
oh my god you start watching prager you
i mean where's the shout out i mean i
guess that's what this is really about
it's like rike
i've got three of i think the top 20
prageru videos in terms of use it's like
i've radicalized people come on man give
me a little credit over here
and then of course netanyahu
used a video to defend israel now again
you didn't criticize any of the ideas in
the video but
this is what progressives do with
everything
that is a paranoid lunatic who should
probably seek
mental health like i don't i honestly
don't know how to describe it anymore
than this like when you see someone like
joy reid
who will not tell you that antifa is
burning down cities when you see people
like this man
who are completely delusional it's just
this idea and then you're gonna watch
this the next thing you know you're
watching ben shapiro before you know it
you're a white supremacist from an
orthodox jew it's all
so stupid but they they keep making
these videos